welcome to this free
webinar on genomic data analysis
this webinar is part of a special six
months
program developed in collaboration with
noguchi memorial
institute for medical research in ghana
omics logic programs are a result of
close collaboration between pine biotech
and innovative welcome to this free
webinar
on
i apologize for the interruption let me
start by sharing my screen again
so as i was talking to you about the
omics logic programs
they are part of a result of close
collaboration between pine biotech
and numerous academic institutions
around the world who have participated
in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design as
a result the omics logic programs have
been thoroughly
tested around the world and are known to
lead to excellent
outcomes for students with minimal
bioinformatics background
including biology and biomedical studies
majors
as well as faculty interested in
bioinformatics data science
and biomedical research the goal of the
omits logic programs
is to provide training in bioinformatics
enabling
independent research guided by mentors
and pure example
developing a growing community with
shared passion for data-driven research
and appreciation of citizen science
enabling students clinicians and faculty
of all backgrounds to develop novel and
independent research
using latest technology in life and data
sciences
our goal is to prepare biologists and
clinicians for the influx of data
associated methodologies and data driven
research projects
as they are prominent with the emergence
of computers for the tech industry
more and more biologists and clinicians
are now expected to understand and
handle their own data
to publish and succeed in basic and
translational research
in fact biology itself is rapidly
acquiring the character of
data science so this is what we hope
to achieve through these omics logic
programs
so the first of this six months program
was the bioinformatics for infectious
diseases focused on the use of
bioinformatics
and big data for infectious disease
research diagnostics as well as drug and
vaccine development
this program is going to be ending on
march
10th one of the major focuses of this
program was to support
ongoing research projects which are
spearheaded by
dr anita gansha and dr bright adu's
group
at nogoji and her collaborators who have
a long history of research in
ghana and other countries in sub-saharan
africa
to track monitor diagnose and study the
spread of drug resistant malaria
as well as identify novel approaches for
vaccine design
as well as the interaction between
malaria host
vector and pathogen to help conduct such
research
the upcoming omics logic genomic data
analysis program
is the second phase of the six month
long program in this period
of training participants would get an
in-depth overview of concepts and
analytical tools
used to study genomic variations in
infectious diseases
each week participants
will meet online to discuss various
aspects
of ngs data processing genomic data
analysis
and interpretation the program starts on
march 12th and today we are going to be
talking about
this program at length
in the genomics program one of the major
focus will be on the application of
bioinformatics to maladra related
research
where we will be looking at the efficacy
of vaccines and drugs
associated with resistance and the
complexity of host pathogen vector
interaction for this purpose our team
has already prepared a number of
research data repositories
and databases that will help the
participants identify
high impact data sets for analysis you
can see
some of them published in our recent
blogs so dr mohit if you can kindly
share the blog with everyone in the chat
we will also discuss various
applications of genomics to the study of
sars cove 2 where selective pressure on
various proteins
will lead to the emergence of new
variants
such changes are already being seen as a
result of
increased immunity vaccination and other
host pathogen dynamics
in this upcoming omics logic program you
will have the opportunity
to interact and collaborate with our
international team of
mentors let me introduce you to them
we have dr harpreet carr who is a
certified omix logic trainer and expert
by information
she will guide the hands-on sessions and
assist participants
with research projects and analysis
during the program
her area of specialization is in
genomics and machine learning
dr mohit mazumdar is our omics logic
project mentor
and an expert in big data computational
analysis
he has a phd in computational biology
and over 10 years of experience working
with industry and academia
elia brodsky is the ceo and co-founder
of find biotech in his current role
he has extensive experience working
together with
industry and academic partners who are
applying multi-omics
integration and bioinformatics to a
variety of biotechnology
and clinical applications i will now
invite
elia to speak more about genomic data
analysis
over to you elia thank you thank you
very much pipsa and welcome everyone to
this webinar
great to see you as we get started i'll
talk a little bit about
the genomic data and what kinds of
research we're planning to do in this
program
but i also wanted to get to know a
little bit more
some of the participants today so if you
um can please share maybe
which country you're coming from to this
webinar
and also if you can share the name of
your university
so that we have a list
of contacts that are here today
let me just check on the chat all right
great so we have somebody from
italy from india university of delhi
the philippines pakistan
iran india
all right university of karachi chile
india all right
paraguay um university of management
technology
cairo university lucknow india china
all right canada egypt bolivia
nigeria all right excellent so
a lot of people tanzania tanzania kenya
all right excellent so welcome everyone
okay welcome everyone to this webinar i
hope that
you enjoyed today's presentation and
that you will be able to join us for the
extensive training program that we will
have
starting in march
so in the last 20 years availability of
genomic data
has led to an increasing understanding
of how cells function
at the molecular level and has allowed
us to understand
some of the major causes of deadly
diseases
and with the current rise in viral
outbreaks persistent bacterial
and parasitic diseases and their
persisting deadliness
there's a major focus on developing
tools
data repositories and analysis methods
for a better understanding
of the reasons why these diseases emerge
how we can treat them and how can they
be potentially prevented with measures
like vaccines
and so as a result there has been a
major effort
to collect data sets that can
characterize describe and help us track
the emergence
and the spread of these diseases so in
fact
you can see that this information is
becoming
not only collected but widely accessible
and so there are millions of sequences
and hundreds of thousands of full
genomes that are available
on repositories that are hosted by the
national center for biotechnology
information
ncbi and many other data sets databases
sorry like joint genome
institutes integrated microbial genome
databases and these databases are
growing in size
at an exponential speed and
we recently saw that some of these are
becoming
more and more visible even to the public
as we see how the call to apply
bioinformatics tool tools to the
analysis of such data
are coming out for example in a recent
review article in nature there has been
a call
to train more people to be able to
utilize genomic data
to help track and spread the disease
uh as you know code 19 caused by source
code
too so these kinds of data sets because
they're so widely available
you can see that that it's easy to find
and download this kind of data it's easy
to
kind of develop a way to track
the newly published data sets but
there's more to the story in fact in the
same article
on nature that was published i think a
couple of days ago
it's been reported that even though we
have many
a lot of information about confirmed
cases coming out
the number of sequences varies
drastically by country
and the quality of that sequences
sequencing
is even further kind of a subject to
investigation
so whenever we have this explosion of
data
and public awareness of the type of
information that this data can produce
we also need to understand how this data
can be properly analyzed and
what kind of information can we get out
of this type of
data so bioinformatics methods that find
individual mutations
like multiple sequence alignments can be
combined with
evolutionary models which we need to
understand and track changes in the
genomic sequences that we can link to a
process
and these models fit to thousands of
genomes to reveal
the dynamic tree of the pandemic which
shows that the virus for example in
in the case of covet 19 continues to
change with novel distinct clades
separating from a common origin over the
course of the past year and so now we
know that there are approximately
12 distinct clades and their number has
grown as you can see there have been
three clades identified just since
november 2020.
the clay proportions are likely to be
unreliable
as i mentioned because of the different
levels of sequencing and the
quality of sequencing done in different
countries but
nevertheless this information has become
prominent and central because
all of us are used to seeing this kind
of information even in the media
so as we think about the dynamic
character of viral infections and
infectious diseases in general
we might ask the question why
or what are the processes and kind of
the reasons
for such variation and dynamics over
time
so what has recently been reported is
that we now understand
how pathogenesis mechanisms of
interaction between the viral
and the or the pathogen and the host the
spread
of resistance and even immune responses
can all play
major roles in how we observe the
genomic sequence
changes in these kinds of data sets so
here you can see how
different reports from a kind of a time
course of infection and different types
of analyses from convalescent plasma
have led to our understanding how these
mutations evolve
and how do they appear in the genomic
sequences
and in fact we now know that the
individual viral genomes that we are
typically thinking of a virus are
actually whole communities or swarms
of what viruses that could be referred
to as quasi species
and so today this is becoming an
important part of diagnostic
assays so here you can see a publication
that shows the representation of the
hypothetical
impact of comorbidity on source code ii
quasi species generation and testing
where wild type stars cove two or the
most common form
is a reference for development of a
diagnostic
real-time pcr assay
or so here you can see how
this type of information could lead to a
much better understanding
of comorbidities inflammation
and increased rates in mutations that
occur
in specific populations so as we develop
novel techniques and a deeper
understanding of what genomic data can
produce
we also need to evaluate the methods of
analysis that have
developed tremendously over the past 20
to 30 years and today we can even look
beyond individual mutations for example
a recent another recent article
it talks about multinucleotide deletions
where whole
regions are being deleted from these
genomes
and how those impact specific clades in
the phylogenetic tree
and even phenotype like the ability to
cause persistent infection and more
severe
infection so as a result what we have
done
is we have tried to introduce a number
of such important tools for genomic data
analysis
into a user-friendly t bioinfo platform
that allows anyone biologists clinicians
as well as bioinformaticians that have
to deal with
hundreds or even thousands of samples at
a time to analyze this type of data
efficiently
on these uh on our platform we
provide specially designed sections to
deal with
infectious disease and other type of
data
so in the context of this genomics
program what we want to do
is go through all the different types of
analysis methods that are available
so that we can try to apply them to
specific types of infectious outbreaks
that are relevant for this cohort so
we'll talk again
about sequence alignment and mapping how
to detect variants
based on multiple sequence alignment or
look for variants and their proportions
in next generation sequencing fast q
files
we'll also talk about analysis that
allows us to look
at frequency of mutations as well as
call
variants with specific level of
confidence
and use that to find differential
mutations or mutations that can
differentiate between different groups
of samples in our data
we'll also talk about the process of
annotating those
mutations and understanding the impact
of the mutations on the
amino acid or the protein sequences
we'll look at a number of different
types of pipelines that could be built
using standardly used tools with some
modification
and we'll look for also advanced
analyses like copy number variation
we'll also see how genomic data matched
with
numeric data about phenotypes can help
us detect specific variants that are
responsible and combinations of variants
in fact that are responsible for
phenotypes such as resistance
to specific drugs or vaccines we'll also
go beyond the scenes and go
into how we can create reports using
r and python loading the final sequence
alignment
and producing detailed reports on
specific positions
and also on how these positions could be
used to understand the variation
in the data and how to select the
specific types of
mutations that are most commonly
reported
and used for example the variance of
concern
in the case of source code ii and so the
two major directions for this
upcoming genomics program is to talk
about
malaria and covet 19 or stars cover ii
so for malaria we'll speak about
different aspects
of the importance of understanding of
the overall
infection cycle and how that infection
cycle can
can help us put a context on the genomic
data
with different tools like sequence
alignment as well as
visualization and working with 3d
structures of proteins
so in this program you will see how we
will cover
a number of specific types of analyses
starting from the very basics going on
into user-friendly analysis tools and
project examples
and then incorporate some of the
training in coding
in python and r so that most of you that
join this program
are enabled and are experienced enough
to be able to design and develop
your own genomics research projects
related to
infectious diseases so this is a program
that we've done before on
different types of diseases like cancer
and others
but here we will focus specific on the
application
specifically on application of genomics
to infectious diseases
now some of you joining today might not
have a lot of background genomics so we
will provide you with information
starting from the very basics so we'll
talk about
the basic terminology what are the
building blocks of dna
and various types of dna variation like
synonymous and non-synonymous mutations
what is frequency of variance how do we
differentiate between single nucleotide
polymorphisms or snips
and copy number variation you'll become
knowledgeable
how to use these terms appropriately to
describe
different types of variants and master
several examples
of their importance in various
conditions
we'll also discuss the process of dna
sequencing and the different types of
dna sequences that you might find online
and we'll see how the analysis of whole
genome and exome sequencing
can be used to find variance and study
association between genotype and
phenotype
we'll also introduce you to self-guided
exemplar projects that will talk about
different types of infections
that are important and relevant to
genomic data
for example we'll talk about ebola virus
the outbreak in 2014 2016
how to find specific genomic uh
genomes in cell lines that are used for
biologics
we'll talk about the origins and
pathogenesis of the novel coronavirus
and we'll see how to use genome-wide
association studies
to understand tuberculosis infection and
drug resistance so when we talk about
ebola
it's a great example because it was one
of the first
outbreaks that we saw almost real time
generation and sharing of large-scale
genomic data
in this project you will see how the
tracking
of the infection can be applied
to genomic data that is available on
ncbi
virus and you will be able to create
phylogenetic trees to study genomic
association
with geolocation as well as time
you'll also see how mapping of those
mutations between nucleotide and amino
acid sequence
reveals important variation in groups of
samples that are available on these
public repositories
but we'll also go beyond that and we'll
talk about this
intra-host variation where you can see
local haplotype reconstruction
using methods that analyze closely
related sequences
in raw reads of fastq files as a result
you will be able to use this information
to track ebola virus transmission
and see the impact of specific variants
on
vaccine design in another project on the
origin and pathogenesis of the novel
coronavirus we will also talk about how
we can detect
where was the first emergence of this
important pathogen
and how we can use phylogenetic analysis
to track the development of this
pandemic
and try to see how closely related this
novel pathogen
is to some of the previously studied and
well characterized coronaviruses
again we'll use multiple sequence
alignment where we compare
different sequences from sars bats
pangolin
and other types of coronaviruses to
understand the impact of specific
genomic variations
on protein structure and interaction
but we'll also talk about the emergence
of
treatment approaches to this important
pathogen and we'll see how
transcriptomic data
can also be used to find association
between treatment response
and specific types of pathways that are
responsible for
efficacy and inflammation so ultimately
you will find
that the application of genomic data
will be described for viral genomics and
evolution
for immune response and biomarkers and
microbiome and infection and so we will
lead
from genomic data characterization into
multi-omics integration
ultimately linking the genomic variants
with pathway analysis in another example
for tuberculosis
we'll talk about genome-wide association
studies where
our goal is to find the association
between
specific individual variants and
the different types of resistance to
either
a single type of treatment or multi-drug
resistance where
multiple types of treatments are being
used so in that case you will learn
how to use genome wide association
studies
and use different approaches for gys
analysis
to ideally understand the specific
genes and their mutations in the context
of many many different samples that we
will analyze together
and so we will also look at how to
produce a report
and characterize the resistance
emergence
throughout different regions around the
world
now as i mentioned genomic data
characterization
has improved to the level where we can
go beyond
individual mutations and start looking
at other types of outbreaks
where defective genomes are responsible
for spread
and disease process so here we will
use the enterovirus d68
which was reported across the different
parts of the globe
especially in the us and europe and
we will see an outbreak of this virus
in 2012 2014 and 2016
where there was a different
pathogenicity between
different populations so here we will
use
a phylogenetic tree reconstruction
algorithm
to find out whether evd68 strains from
different outbreaks at different
time points are similar or different
based on the phylogenetic analysis
of patient data here we will use the
variation
and the strains to identify clades
related to specific dates of outbreaks
and we will finally look at how specific
variants can characterize these
individual strains
that are either on the nucleotide or the
amino
acid level so to talk about how you can
gain access to a lot of these program
resources
i will pass this back on to bipsa and
she will introduce you to
the process of registration
thank you so much elia so i will
continue by
sharing my screen right here
so as i'm going to be starting talking a
little bit about the program resources
i want to get started by launching a
poll here
on the screen so this is just a poll to
know more about who you are
as you see that in the chat we have uh
participants who are coming
from different countries around the
world they have different
interests so please let us know the
first question here as you see is which
country you are from
so there are several options if you're
from any other country
then you can mention the other countries
that you're from
in the chat box the second question is
what is your level of education
then the third is how familiar are you
with genomics as we are talking
primarily about genomics
so we are going to be asking you the
question but
in case you're also interested in any
other topic
like anirudh mentioned more about ngos
data analysis focused on transcriptomics
or microbiome data analysis so if you're
interested in any of these topics you
can also let us know
in the chat box and if you share your
email id with us
so we will be reaching out to you and
the last
question i wanted to add here was
how did you learn about the genomics
webinar so where did you
come to know about this webinar that
you're attending today did you receive
an email from us did you see
the webinar on facebook linkedin
instagram or was it recommended to you
by any friend or
peer or faculty please put them down
in the post so we'll keep the poll on
for just another minute
while i answer a question from polo me
in the chat box
so polo me says i'm an undergraduate
biotechnology student can i do any of
the courses you're providing
yes follow me you can do any of the
courses we are providing
and this is because of the program
resources that i'm going to be sharing
so you will notice that when we are
talking about the resources it starts
with courses
which begin at a very primary
and introductory level so we give you
access to these resources from where you
can start learning
and supplement that learning along with
online sessions
like this webinar that we are having
today so as part of the omics logic
genomics program
we will be having online sessions i will
be quickly taking
everybody through that schedule shortly
and also show you how you will be
learning from each of these resources so
every week
we'll give you some assignments give you
some tasks that you have to complete and
this you can do
along with any of the other studies that
you're doing
if you're a college student or if you
have uh if you are pursuing your phd you
can do this
so if you are looking forward to join a
program like this
we recommend a minimum of six to eight
hours per week if you
want to make the best out of the program
and even if you are someone who is very
busy
may not be able to attend all of the
online sessions
we also record each of the session
videos and send it to our participants
so the session recordings will also be
available for all of the sessions that
we will
be doing
okay so i'm reading some of the
questions that are here
so i will also be introducing everybody
to the other programs
that are available uh as part of the
omix logic programs that we do and we
have several of those but today as we
are focused on
genomics and infectious diseases so we
are going to be talking a little bit
about this
and moving into the other programs and
everybody who is sharing please continue
to post
your uh email ids or any of the
feedback that you have in the chat box
uh today's session tanvi is free of
course a training program
is not free of cost so i will be talking
about
the costs right at the end so i think uh
we have received the poll
uh so uh elia doctor can you confirm
because i cannot see if the poll is
being done
so i can end the poll now
yes i think you can end the poll i see
there's been
okay thank you so much india so i will
be ending the poll now thank you all for
sharing
so omix logic program is built to
provide students of all backgrounds
with a clear perspective on big data
analytics machine learning and
artificial intelligence in application
to omics data
for research clinical and industry
applications
our omics logic step-by-step process
is enabled by access to complex tools
via a simple and intuitive interface
at the same time exposing participants
to analysis logic
in the context of real data sets and
extrapolation of this logic
to a variety of projects and data sets
with assistance from mentors
and technical support as we have seen
india
tell us so far
the program licenses include access to
tutorials and project
examples big data analysis
tools coding training and mentor support
so this is all included in all of the
program licenses and i'm going to be
talking
in depth about this in short while
so let us start by signing up to eduti
bio info
so if you are not already a member of
the platform
please start by signing up to edut buyer
if you can kindly share the link in the
chat box
the edutiba info portal
has introductory courses which leads to
multiple
other courses and projects that can
serve as a springboard into the world of
bioinformatics
and here learning about genomic data
analysis
and we also have several projects that
you see
some of which elia has also discussed
for the duration of the program we will
also be using the tbio info platform to
process
big data sets this platform is built for
multi-omics integration and analysis of
structured data with advanced methods
like machine learning and mathematical
modeling
for downstream analysis and
visualization of process
data there are many packages in popular
coding languages
like r and python which you can learn on
the code
omics logic playground additional coding
exercises
will also be used to practice sequence
alignment
evolutionary studies and interpretation
of found
variants
so let us now go together to see how to
register for this program
so for this i will be sharing my screen
and on my screen you have the
registration page link
thank you all for sharing the email id
right now so this is the registration
link
so now let's quickly take a look at what
we can see in this page so we have the
start date which is 12th of march
so we are going to be starting very soon
in less than 10
days the program time is the same time
that we started today which is 9 00 am
cst
or 9 am central standard time
and if you are from any other country
outside of the us
please convert it to your local time in
india time it will be 8
30 p.m ist in gmt it will be 3 pm gmt
and once you go down here we have also
prepared a video for the session that
you can see so you can learn more about
what we are going to be talking about
here is a program overview and once you
scroll down
you find the schedule for the session
so here is the entire schedule for the
session so you can actually go through
the different topics that we will be
dealing with
in each of these sessions and we will
have bi-weekly sessions here
and let me take you through the
registration process so once you're in
this page
if you're looking forward to get started
you have to click on get started and you
will notice that
we offer three licensing options so this
is what i was referring to
when i meant that we offer licensing for
this program
so these licenses cover the resources
that we have just spoken about
earlier so we have a beginner's license
so what does the beginner license
constitute off the beginner license
constitutes of
all the resources we mentioned which is
the asynchronous course materials the
live sessions the hands-on assignments
group sessions as well as projects
and how is it different from the
intermediate and advanced
so the intermediate comes with an extra
benefit where you can request
time for one of the mentors to mentor
you
on a one-on-one session so if you have
any questions
or if you feel like that you want to
take the program at a pace as well as
learn from one-on-one sessions and not
just the group
sessions you can request for this and
for that you can take the intermediate
license
while the advanced license is a research
license
which means that if you are looking
forward to doing research using genomics
data
or similar kind of data then what we
recommend
is having the advanced license so what
does the advanced license give you it
gives you an
additional 30 days so we already see
that
the program is going to be ending on
15th april
so you for you if you're taking the
advanced license it's going to be giving
you additional 30 days so which means
that your program access will end on
the 15th of may and
you can actually do a research project
in that
extra period of time along with our
mentor team
and also work together with the research
fellows we have
and thank you so much bhagat singh for
sharing
so these are the different options we
have for payment
and we will be sharing any other details
that you require and we also understand
that there are some students who might
need help in joining the session
so we also offer scholarship so i will
also paste the scholarship
link right in the chat box and the goal
of the scholarship
is to offer students who are bright and
who might need help in attending
a training program like this and there
are some requirements that a student
would need to follow
to fill up and to get access to the
program
as part of the scholarship so if you
noticed
on this page you have a form now what
you need to do is if you're applying for
the scholarship please make sure
that you're filling up all of these
fields so if you just write
nil your scholarship will not be granted
so
we need to especially meet with you
and your reference so this is very
important
the goal is to make sure that you are
going to be following through
a program like this that the faith that
we are providing you the scholarship you
are going to be
doing the tasks that are assigned to you
so basically if you are receiving a
scholarship
you will be assigned few tasks which
means that you have to give us constant
updates of your progress throughout the
training you have to
send us reviews of the courses that you
do so you have to be very
involved in this entire training so once
you're
filling out the form please make sure
you do this as soon as possible because
we will have to set up meetings with you
and one of your references who can be
from the institute or the university
that you come
from so we also present to them this
opportunity we talk with you
and then based on that discussion you
are offered the scholarship
so if you want to take scholarship for
this program
please mention here as well which
program you're applying for
for and you can anybody can apply for
this scholarship but it will only be
given
once we have that discussion with you
so uh bhagat can you see the chat box
i've shared the scholarship link again
and i will
also share the link for the genomics
program right here on the chat box
here again and while i'm talking about
this i also wanted to invite everybody
to join our social media groups
so in the social media groups you will
see that we have
a lot of participants who are coming
from different parts of the world
and they are just like you scholars
students researchers as well as
faculties and administrators from
different parts of the world so it's a
great place
for you to go ahead and get started
knowing
from different people and collaborating
with us so we believe in collaboration
we do hope that we are able to
collaborate with you and we also have a
facebook page
so i'm also sharing the link here
of the facebook page
and let me paste it in the chat box so
these are the few pages that we have for
different sections and whoever
whichever social media you are
comfortable
using and we also have
other programs that are coming up so as
anirudh was
requesting we do have this
transcriptomics program that we started
on second month so we have had
only one session so far the next session
is going to be
on friday which is march 5th so anirudh
if you are interested in learning more
about
ngs data analysis and not only under
anybody else
who is interested in learning more about
uh this kind of data analysis you can go
ahead and check out this link the
registration process
is the same as well as the scholarship
link remains the same just when you are
applying for the scholarship please
mention the program that you are
interested in
as we have several different programs
that we are running
at the moment so i do hope that you all
are
able to take part in programs like this
and take this opportunity
and i'll quickly stop sharing and find
the link to the other programs for
everybody here
so okay this is the link to the other
programs that we
are having as part of
the several omics logic programs that we
are doing this
spring summer so let me quickly again
share my screen
and share this link so via this link
what you can do
is see the different programs that we
have
so we have a research fellowship program
shubham we do not offer any phd programs
but we do have a program on research
fellowship and i will quickly explain
what it is
the goal of this program is to help you
design or develop your own novel
research project
so this is a program completely focused
on research projects it's offered for
either three months or
six months and we work with students we
work with even high school students who
are doing really well under this program
where
they are getting started on their
research journey way earlier and that is
possible using the
resources that we offer like the big
data analysis server platform
that you saw which has multi-omics
integration so you can understand the
different applications and how easy it
is because
it's there in the cloud and a student
just needs to log into the platform
in the browser and use the platform
so this is the bioinformatics research
fellowship program
and the next program that we have is
this program that we are seeing today
which is the
omics logic genomic program so whenever
you are applying for any of these
programs
please make sure that you're selecting
the program you're interested in
and this is the omics logic training
program that we are running currently in
india but we also accept any kind of
international participation
and whoever is joining us now
and we also have another program coming
up focused
on precision oncology
so this program is going to be starting
on march 15th
and this is also another program where
we are going to be focusing
more on cancer biology tumor development
etc and if you are someone who is
working with cancer
or you are interested in going towards a
research area like this then you can
also apply for this program
and i'll just show you how to apply for
this so you notice that there is a form
at the end of the page
and you can actually choose from this
different programs that you would want
to apply for so once you select a
program you will receive an
email regarding the program so please
make sure that you are selecting the
program of your choice
and if you want to apply for multiple
programs then please fill up the form
twice
and make sure you're selecting the
options uh different options at this
different time periods
and thank you so much if you all have
any questions so research fellowship
right
so okay so manisha what do you want to
know more about the research fellowship
if you can let me know then maybe i can
clarify it for you
while for mega genomics yes we just
concluded
a metagenomic program so we had this
metagenomic program
uh that we started in february so it's
going to be expiring very soon
so for all the programs so all the
programs have different
costs so you would have to go ahead and
subscribe and see what all these
programs cost for
so maybe you can reach out to me i obama
and i can share with you if you want to
join all of these programs and please
note that
some of the sessions may be clashing so
we would recommend you to start with one
and then progress to others because
we'll keep on repeating
uh these kinds of programs even in the
coming summer months
so this is my email id thank you uh dr
mohit
marketing at pine dot bio is my email id
for reaching out to me
yeah thank you and for everyone reaching
out for us to
for these different programs that we are
offering so this is the website where
you can actually apply for these
programs and then you will get emails
about the entire process that how we are
going to conduct the sessions when the
program is going to start
and all the other details like the free
sessions that we are doing associated
with this
these programs and also for research
fellowship
we are doing this with participants who
have uh
who have learned from one of the omics
logic programs and now they want to work
on their project and finalize the
project and trans
uh and then move to a way
where they can present the project and
show it to their peers and also like may
be published
so that's the entire uh structure of the
research fellowship program
however i mean if you're interested
please go to this link and fill up the
form and we'll be
emailing you as well thank you yeah
thank you so much dr mohit
and um i would just want to answer some
of the questions which i see right now
so when exactly is the research
fellowship starting
so the research fellowship does not have
a commencement date
our research fellows work throughout the
year on different research projects what
we aim to do is help you
develop your own research project so you
can start joining
today and we you will get started with
your three month or six months research
journey
so the research fellowship again to
answer swati's question
be will it be containing details on data
science applications with health care
so each of the research fellowship
program
is focused on training you in an area
you are interested in and developing a
project so maybe if you are interested
in working on a project
we start with the training and help you
go through this and elia will also be
explaining the process
shortly and to
answer avoca's question
is the application for research
fellowship free or does scholarship
cover
it as well so the application again for
the research fellowship program
is not free but definitely you can again
go ahead and apply for scholarship
the criterion of selection for
scholarship as i mentioned
is based on the conversation that we
will have with you on a one-on-one
meeting with your mentor
so please make sure that the details
that you're entering is
correct and it would also require you to
perform certain tasks as i mentioned
which we will mention to you during the
meeting that we have
so now i would like to pass back this
session to elia to discuss some of the
projects over to you elia
okay thank you people so again um thank
you everyone for
the informative questions um i briefly
wanted to mention
that many of the programs that you are
seeing here
are designed to help you conduct
independent research and to do
research using bioinformatics it's
important to
find a data set to learn about
the application of different methods and
it's also a collaborative process so you
really need to work with others on
different components of your project
project for example if you come from
a bioinformatics background already
you might want to find a collaborator
that is more biology burst
if you are coming from a biology
background maybe you will find it
challenging to conduct certain types of
research
with coding and computational tools
and also describing your methods so the
program that we have
and we typically have between 10 and 20
fellows at a time we try to facilitate
this process
allowing you to gain access to all of
the different training sessions that we
have
know about the different types of
analysis
using different tutorials and project
examples
and we typically see a slow transition
between
learning to then designing your research
question
and finding the data set that you will
study that question using
and then eventually working with you to
help you
polish up the presentation and
potentially even write a paper
so i pasted a link here to a number of
recent projects that have been completed
by different participants
and i want to just show you this is just
a few examples really
it's not a comprehensive list
but to get you an idea one of the major
kind of stepping stones for a lot of
people once they design a project is to
be able to get some feedback
on what it is like what did people think
about it what do other people who are
either experts in this field
or experts in bioinformatics what can
they say about the project and so
typically that has been done
in the context of poster presentations
where students can present their posters
and get some feedback answer questions
etc so
we essentially provide an online version
of that
by conducting regular meetings where
both
experts and other peers can provide
feedback to
a project presentation and also
eventually when the project is done and
sometimes that project is ready for a
publication we guide you on how to
submit that publication and help you
make sure that the draft is good
and then also we have a number of
collaborators at the tower
bioinformatics research center and in
other places that we
uh asked to evaluate the project
from an expert perspective
and so here are some examples of posters
that
range from alzheimer's disease
to cancer to infectious diseases and
others
some people take very cutting edge
projects like
the effect of radiation on the
microbiome in space
and other people apply it to very
immediate types of challenges
you can see here for example
identification imaging of potential
vaccine targets versus our scope 2
spikes so a really
diverse range of projects that are
either
done independently like here you see a
project by urja
and sometimes in groups here you can see
a collaboration between a number of
different people that work together
so oftentimes i think as a result of
such collaborations you get to
understand a project from multiple
perspectives
and it also in the context of a short
time
frame can prepare you for a longer plan
to conduct a project in a more thorough
way so for example
our bioinformatics for infectious
disease program with the university of
ghana
is scheduled for six months and the
reason for that is because just now
after
maybe a month and a half of training the
participants are starting to
really work on their project
presentations
and that's one of the things that i
actually wanted to mention that
we have an upcoming session where you
can see
some of those presentations where
students and
faculty and researchers that have
completed some
training program will be sharing their
uh projects uh proposals project
proposals
so we will have this available on march
10th it will be a session where we will
have some of our research fellows
present some of the people that have uh
worked under a scholarship uh that have
summarized kind of what they have
learned
and we will have some of the
participants of the first phase of the
bioinformatics for infectious disease
program
where you will find proposals on malaria
and on source cove too so
beeps i don't know if you can share the
link
for this session or if you have
submitted your email address we will be
emailing you
that information uh maybe by the end of
this week
so we welcome those of you especially
those of you that are interested
in applying bioinformatics to different
research problems to reach out to us
maybe some of you would like to speak
about
your project and about your
you know what to do with your project
essentially so
please do reach out to us dr muhit
mazumdar here
is curating a lot of data sets and
helping
groups of students kind of develop their
project proposals
so you can definitely reach out to us
marketing at pine dot bio or mojit
at pine dot bio to schedule a
discussion about your project and
we also want to mention that in many
cases
the way this works best is for faculty
that do not have sufficient time
to dedicate to a project but would like
help
from their students guiding being guided
by some
expert to develop an analysis so another
option is really to
join a program together with your
students maybe two or three students
that can do
the analysis and you can kind of provide
the oversight and guidance
on selecting the topic and making sure
that the analysis is good
so if you have any questions about those
please do reach out to us
specifically and i'll pass it on back to
you
beep said to kind of answer some of the
questions that are being asked
thank you so much ilya and thank you uh
manassa for
sharing the sharing with us this
feedback i hope that everybody is
now able to see my screen so
at this point i would like to ask if you
have any other questions
please feel free to reach out to us so
we have shared three email ids in the
chat box one is move it
bio to reach out to dr mohit regarding
any kind of questions that you may have
regarding projects collaborations
if you want to reach out to us regarding
the research fellowship the programs or
any other opportunities please feel free
to reach out to me
marketing at pine.bio even regarding any
kind of access that you
would want to different websites that we
have or the different portals that we
offer
and we also have a team in africa based
out of nigeria
so you can reach out to our africa team
if you're based out in nigeria
africa or ghana or any of these
countries
uh africa at pine dot bio is the email
id
so if you do not have any other
questions
thank you all for joining today's
session
so uh you can reach out to
adidas is a community manager
in africa so regarding any kind of
uh problems with get credit card or any
other payment issues for participants
in africa nigeria please reach out to
aditayo so africa pi not bio is the
email id
you can also send that email to me and i
will be able to
help you connect with adidas as well
so thank you adida for sharing this so
do we have any other questions and thank
you polo me
for sharing the feedback
thank you burhan thank you
okay yeah so delago yes we do have
professionals
as well who apply for this program which
means that professionals who belong to
any of these domains
in biotechnology bioinformatics
and they too would want to learn more
about bioinformatics application
especially industry professionals so yes
we do also
train them so if you have any specific
requests regarding that please reach out
to me i will be able to help you
so again i would like to invite
everybody to connect with us
so here you would be able to see the
different
people who are there in the groups
interact with them we do hope that
you're able to interact with us and ask
us questions as well
we are also active on instagram
so please go ahead and follow us
on these links on instagram you can find
us
at bioinformatics spine and we are also
there on youtube so our youtube channel
name is fine biotech as you saw that dr
mother shared earlier we had streamed
this session live on youtube
so it will be available there for review
if you want to go
go ahead and review this later
so thank you all i would want to end
today's session i look forward to
seeing you all in the upcoming omixlogic
genomic program or any of the other
programs that we are offering
have a wonderful day everyone and please
feel free to
email us regarding any questions that
you may have
thank you and have a good